[Music]
the flower industry
is a 100 billion pound global business
britain is the world's fourth largest
buyer of cut flowers
but do we ever really think about where
they come from
in fact a startling 90 percent we buy
are foreign
i mean look at that it's just beautiful
it just kept your heart going really
where is it
kenya rose
dominating the international flower
trade holland controls over half of the
global market
their 24-hour 365 days a year
hyper technical monster flower factories
and growing fields
churn out almost 200 000 flowers an hour
the gulf is enormous we've got about 500
growers compared to the 10 000 they've
got in holland
speaks for itself doesn't it really for
decades the dutch have forged ahead by
directly supporting their own flower
industry
the uk has just not kept up there's a
david and goliath situation when you
compare
british flower grows to dutch flower
grows but that doesn't mean that the
cause is lost
we go behind the scenes of the dutch
flower industry and our own flower
markets farms and factories
to discover how we are being encouraged
to buy british once again
with new trends for provenance and local
sourcing britain's growers are biting
back
we're not shouting it from the rooftops
you know i think that's the key
difference i think with the dutch
they like to chat about it we like to
get on with it we reveal how britain's
event florists are leading the world
with their creativity
i do love my british flowers and do hope
that one day there will be more growers
and they will have the variety and the
industry will continue to grow
flowers can't die out and we show how
cleverly supermarkets have influenced
the way we choose and buy our flowers
we sell sirloin we sell phillips
we leave the stewing stake values
supermarkets
the value mints to the garage full
courts
come to the florence florists are a
miserable bunch
is there what's the point in carrying on
we're not doing anything you know the
supermarket's taking all the trade
supermarkets have done a power of good
for us
just how and where we choose to buy our
flowers from
says more about us as a nation than you
may ever realize
[Music]
it's 4 a.m at the uk's largest most
exclusive wholesale flower market
cotton garden tons of the world's best
quality flowers are turning up ready for
the early morning floristry trade
young lady that's called pink piano
panda stem take that picture
have a good day bud thank you
i think it's just an institution in it
there's nothing else like it it's just
really british i think it's like a
little
slice of london life that people don't
always realize that's here
how you doing anna super babe
every time i see you get better looking
how good is that rose
it's called london iron nigella sir
loving the mist or shag in the dark
there's lovely flowering mints dennis
edwards
has sold flowers here for 50 years
that's campanella the dutchman called
him piss pots
seriously covent garden sells almost a
quarter of a million pounds worth of
flowers a day
but since its heyday in the 50s it's
declined
its survival now rests not on price but
on selling top quality
cut flowers
i won't see a box of flowers like that
anywhere else in the world
they are the dogs of whiskers there's
500 quid in that box here
it's really the valley and it's one of
the most popular flowers in the world
eddie martin has worked at covent garden
for 36 years
and is the third generation to sell
flowers here
they led them in a vase so of bent down
like that all hanging over the vases
in restaurants or hotels you know even
in
a lot of the russian billionaires
millionaires they'll have all them in
their homes
and it's working 75 percent of florists
in the southeast
now buy their flowers here
oh that's beautiful
the most successful flies come to the
market basically
they come here and they want the best so
we sell them
and then they turn it into something
special
it's really amazing what they do
there's just more volume here i've got
more choice yeah maybe you do pay a
little bit more
you know the quality of the product but
ultimately you get what you pay for
many sellers at cotton garden grew up in
an industry where british flowers ruled
fifty years ago virtually all the
flowers sold in the uk were british home
grown
but imports from europe have shattered
our flower industry
and now most of the flowers that we
purchase are no longer grown in britain
in fact almost 90 percent of the flowers
we buy
are foreign mostly dutch
the dutch were heavily subsidised they
had a lot of
help developing their industry whereas
at the same time our industry was really
just forgotten about we were a
cinderella industry
all the grants went to agriculture and
horticulture had to fare for
itself
[Music]
holland is now the world's largest most
advanced cut flower producing nation
supplying most of the flowers that end
up in our homes
unlike in the uk most dutch blooms are
grown in greenhouses so efficient
some produce more energy than they use
reducing carbon dioxide and generating
10 percent of holland's power needs
their computerized automated greenhouses
and flower assembly lines
are the envy of the world
[Music]
thousands of dutch growers work together
in a cooperative
running their own super slick
international flower auctions
selling 45 million flowers and plants a
day
their distribution warehouses are the
largest covered roof spaces in the world
holland's plant and flower industry
turns over almost seven billion pounds a
year
that's almost a quarter of all the
world's trade in horticulture
well the gulf is enormous the dutch have
about 10 000 growers
many thousands of hectares of glass over
here we've got about 500 growers
compared to the 10 000 they've got in
holland
speaks for itself doesn't it really the
dutch have been very clever in terms of
adopting new forms of technology to
increase the quality and the yield of
the flowers that they produce
back in britain our growers have been
slightly slower with that which means
we're actually years behind
now we can't produce as many flowers we
can't produce them as cheaply
in fact the dutch is so far ahead of us
technologically
that we are struggling to compete when
it comes to england's national flower
the rose the roads are getting better
and better it's very intense
yeah we're getting there
mario land is the largest rose producer
in europe
over 60 million stems a year
brothers daniel and johan are using some
pretty high-tech approaches
to create and mass-produce the perfect
rose
[Music]
this is much more nice it's more white
it's more
alive many dutch roses are grown in foam
not soil with nutrients delivered in
their water
perfect growing conditions are managed
by computer and the roses get the
crucial carbon dioxide they need to grow
piped in a waste product of power
stations
it's easy to grow roses you plant the
plants you give it water
and soil does the rest for the most part
you want to create
a beautiful product
you have to do it better than the rest
if you want to make money with it
[Music]
pollen's super efficient factories
deliver the highest quality roses
their processing machines churn out over
170
000 roses every day we have a camera
in the back and the camera will take a
look at
how long the roses are how thick the
roses it are
and how big the roses in head size and
also
the opening stage like how open the
roses
the unique setting points of dutch roses
are
the big head size the roses come open
and what you see is that year round we
have a more stable quality
why because we can control the climate
in the greenhouse
so even in the winter we have a good
quality
by creating supernatural growing
conditions dutch roses are forced to
reach their perfect peak quickly
and in vast numbers they look just like
traditional british roses
but with one peculiar difference in
breeding the perfect flower the majority
of these roses
have no smell
growers in holland really decided to
hone in on this put all their technology
and all their expertise into making the
most beautiful roses that they could
the problem with that is these roses
look beautiful but have little to no
scent whatsoever
in the interim years centers become so
much more important
so the dutch girls have now got a
problem they've now got to
scientifically
create scents to go with the roses that
they sell
otherwise we're going to shift our
buying back to british roses which do
have scent
but holland's rose producing empire also
has its own
problems they've been hit by foreign
imports
in the last 15 years three-quarters of
holland's rose growers
have disappeared morning hal
how are you doing yeah sure we're doing
a box
at cotton garden holland's quality roses
have been swamped by cheap arrivals
flown in from africa
and south america seventy percent of all
the roses we buy in the uk
are from kenya this is a dutch bombastic
this is a ethiopian bombastic
different things entirely huh yeah
but sometimes the dutch ones are too
expensive for what customers need then
we have to buy them
a smaller grade if they're using lots of
it um but yeah
roses in bulk consistency
gotta go to ireland almost 90 percent of
flowers at covent garden being foreign
imports
there's still that elusive 10 percent
here that are british
and searching them out is 21 year old
hampshire florist
jay archer he grabbed me that one as
well man yeah
she's cashing in on a new thirst for
homegrown traditional british flowers
and business is booming um can i have
this box of doubts
yeah of course but i like british
flowers because they tend to be
a bit more bendy and a bit more quirky
and a lot of the time you know if they
are field growing
they're going to be a bit weather-worn
currency creature yeah amazing
a lot of the time they are more scented
the british flowers so i think a lot of
the dutch flowers
once they get the quality and the
aesthetic is you know a lot of the time
bang on sometimes too perfect
a lot of the time they don't smell so
you know richard would you rather
we'll keep flying the flag we'll keep it
going
i think it's just education isn't it
fundamentally
[Music]
but the british have still got a long
way to go the dutch have dominated the
flower industry for centuries
there's a david and goliath situation
when you compare british flower grows to
dutch flower grows
but that doesn't mean that the cause is
lost
[Music]
between march and may in the historic
kirkenhoff gardens near amsterdam
500 of holland's top flower growers show
off more than 7 million flowers
holland's stronghold on the industry all
started with their humble national
flower
the tulip
the dutch have also figured out a way of
making more money
by breeding new varieties of flowers
under licence
growers that use dutch breeds pay
royalties for every flower and plant
they grow
that's almost two and a half billion
pounds a year
[Music]
breeding of cup flowers or any product
is absolutely crucial for an industry
but we don't really have a cut flower
breeding program in the uk anymore
it's a downside for the british industry
in some ways but breeding is
very expensive and to breed something
you've got to have a mass market for it
and obviously the dutch already have
that mass market in place
breeding and growing the perfect tulip
has been an obsession for the dutch
since the 16th century
for rich and poor alike the dutch
produce
9 billion chulip bulbs every year
in the land of tulips dutch grower aryan
schmidt
is on the hunt for a very special tulip
that just might provide a future money
spinner
oh this is great this is completely new
we have a mutation in the tube sometimes
the inside information from a tube
he changed completely he's not red and
yellow
and then is it possible that he make in
one year
a new flower at this moment i think i
have a
very beautiful tube but i must wait some
years
and then we have maybe a new variety
we found him together today
when a new variety is bred the challenge
for aryan is how to turn one new bulb
into big enough quantities to sell but
despite the glorious sides of billions
of holland's blooming tulips
surprisingly not one of these will ever
make it to the shops
every spring all across holland five and
a half billion perfect tulips
have their heads chopped off this drives
the growing power of the flower into the
bolts below
making them bigger and stronger
[Music]
every year the bulbs are dug up divided
and grown again
until there are enough bulbs to be grown
into flowers on a commercial scale
every autumn the biggest and the best
bulbs are transferred indoors
to be nurtured through the winter
[Music]
in ariane's cooling sheds thousands of
bulbs are fed water and nutrients
until the first signs of a flower emerge
this is the flower from this variety
it's completely packed
inside the build this is my special room
in this room around eight hundred
thousand kills
ah it's a lot of fuel we can make a lot
of people happy in here
finally three weeks later after being
warmed in the greenhouse
the tulip bulbs are ready to be
harvested as cut flowers
to create a new variety to breed grow
and multiply enough bulbs and flowers to
sell
takes a staggering 25 years
and then we start him and then from this
moment he makes uh
30 000 flowers in an hour and we do that
all the day
seven days a week ariane's tulip
processing machine
throws out the rejects leaving two very
different qualities
for two very different customers
his biggest most expensive tulips with
larger heads and stronger stems
are wrapped in blue paper for florists
and the smaller cheaper flowers in white
are destined for supermarkets
[Music]
ariane's latest batch of best quality
tulips are heading for the dutch auction
houses
and within 48 hours onto britain's
forests
this is my product this is my royal
virgin
and i'm very proud of this variety
it's 5 a.m at nautveg auction house part
of royal flora holland's flower
producing cooperative
it's here that most of the world's
flowers are auctioned and almost 70
percent
are dutch there's only an hour to go
before the auction
and flower buyers are getting in early
in the hope of finding a bargain
delphiniums these will sell a lot of
money probably
about two two and a half euros
[Music]
and one of those is jeff clark from
bexellon c
high street florists like him are
finding it tough over the last 10 years
40 percent have closed jeff's solution
is to go into the lion's den
and buy flowers directly he's been
coming here for the last 30 years
and is the only british florist to do it
it's helped his business thrive
you have to be slim doing this job that
don't give you much room
every week jeff fills his van with
around 3 000 pounds worth of flowers
even with 500 pounds worth of expenses
he gets them for half the price they'd
cost him at wholesalers in the uk
and if things run smoothly i can be back
in the shop before it closes and those
flowers would be in water
and they would have been growing
yesterday and they've come all the way
from holland
and you just can't get fresher than that
we're going to walk in front of this
electric car now and it will stop
look at that yes i like making weight
having been the token brit for so many
years jeff's become a bit of a star
every client is special but jeff is very
special
[Laughter]
i never knew that yeah yeah it's the
first time i'm telling you yes
that's right yes when you've got a
little change yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah well i'm supplying the flowers
for about 10 weddings
and so i've got a lot of very
specialized flowers to get to
today uh including these these are the
uh
sweet avalanche roses they are
absolutely beautiful they're stunning
they come from one of one of the best
growers in the uh in the netherlands
but there are only nine buckets here
through the longer ones six to the
shorter ones so whoever gets in first
bids the most
gets them and i need um two buckets so i
need one third
of the supply of these shorter roses
sweet avalanche if i bid about 80
cents for the 60s do you think that was
secure
yesterday i think uh 85 well they were
85 yards i know they were highs i missed
them so yeah i i go 19. i i just gotta
have one i don't want to
yeah i don't want to go home without
yeah
flowers are automatically transported
and paraded in front of holland's unique
clock bidding system
buyers from around the world bid on the
internet and directly on one of 36
auction clocks generating seven and a
half million pounds a day
holland's auctions sell over 16 billion
plants and flowers a year
that's 120 000 transactions and over 45
million flowers
every day the dutch absolutely dominate
the
flower industry and the dutch auction
system has been key to that
a grower in the uk um has to find
somewhere to sell his flowers to
the dutch will send them to the auction
okay the price they get is out of their
hands
but there is a ready-made market there
to sell them which has been the envy of
the world
unlike in the uk in dutch auctions
prices start high
as the red dot flies around the clock
and slowly starts to drop
buyers register a bid by hitting a
button
if jeff presses his button first he'll
probably get the flowers he wants but
the price will be high
if he waits a split second later it
could be cheaper
but he might miss them
i've gone 24 to make sure i get it i
missed them
it's too quick you have to be so quick
to get everything
and here come the roses i've got to keep
my eye open
because i have got to have the sweet
avalanche roses
i've just got a bid really high to make
sure i get them
i've got them i paid 86 cents for them
and they've gone for 92
90. last one went for 82. so i got it
about right
i don't care i've got them i'm happy
that's the one thing i really
really needed because if i bought them
in england they'd be
horrendously expensive
and to keep jeff's flowers fresh they
need to be divvied up
stacked on bias trolleys and out of the
building as fast as possible
but when the warehouses are the same
size as 300 football pitches
time is of the essence
we have made an agreement with our
clients wherever you are in the building
in 90 minutes you have it all you have
it all
so those 30 000 trolleys
are all separated in
a few hours to the clients that's
amazing that's really amazing
a computer talks to each individual
trolley driver
telling them exactly how many buckets to
drop off and on which buyers trolley
and the drivers talk back counting down
the buckets as they unload them
[Music]
it all leads to a well-orchestrated
high-speed car dance
where speed and accident avoidance is
key
[Music]
it's not surprising that half of the
world's total flowers and plants
are now traded through holland
the entire auction process has taken
jeff nine hours
he's got a six hour journey back by the
channel tunnel the same day
this is gorgeous i wish i bought more of
those now
[Music]
but unlike jeff the vast majority of
britain's florists
aren't so committed to buying their
flights directly
alongside flora holland are hemskirk
flower exporters
loading trucks are their flying dutchmen
the middlemen between the auction houses
and britain's florists 75 of them sell
daily across the uk
each truck carries up to 30 000 pounds
worth of flowers
earning them over a million pounds a
year over 70 percent of britain's
florists
buy directly from these door-to-door
wholesalers taking business away from
flower markets like covent garden
[Music]
flying dutchman willem van reine has
been covering the south coast
supplying the same 30 florists every
week
[Music]
i'm a proper old-fashioned flying
dutchman
i'm working on 29 years over here in
england that's half of my life
so i'm half english that's what i'm
always saying it's what my children
always say to me
to meet the people to sell the flowers
to
getting every day is gonna happen
something what you don't expect
i i simply love it they sell to over
four thousand flower shops across the uk
their flowers may be more expensive than
buying directly
but it's more convenient
[Music]
so nice
[Music]
can i just have 20 vandalism thank you
to get on the van and actually feel and
touch and see it
it's different altogether yeah it's
lovely we get quite excited about it
[Music]
we buy nearly 30 percent of our flowers
from florists
and many still believe that survival
depends on selling
top of the range flowers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we choose to sell dutch roses
i mean look at that i mean it's
beautiful it's beautiful i mean
full strong head it'll last well
um doesn't necessarily have a perfume
but it's just
beautiful it just affects your heart
going really where is it
kenyan rose
down the high street competing for the
same customers are the latest big
players in the flower retail market
supermarkets we don't like
bartering for prices we want to know
exactly what we're getting and that's
why the supermarkets do very well
we know exactly the price of the bouquet
we're going to buy whereas when we go
into a florist and the pricing is a
little bit more ambiguous
to the point that lots don't even put
prices on their stems
we get very nervous about that britain's
florists are now under attack
the nation's supermarkets have managed
to grab almost 60 percent of the
country's flower sales
and they're out for more will britain's
florists survive
[Music]
the 100 billion pound global flower
industry's heart
is firmly in holland the uk can't
compete
and only around 10 of the flowers we buy
are grown in britain
despite tough financial times in the
last five years there's been a surprise
boom in flower sales
20 years ago supermarkets only had 20
percent of the cut flower market
now it's almost sixty percent
what do you think about the protein okay
is that selling well now or do you think
that we're still missing something
inside it
supermarkets have spotted a change in
consumer buying habits
and been quick to exploit it but they
sell
i guess i think they're becoming closer
in front of mine i mean we've got them
in store here next to the newspapers and
magazines so you know as you're going to
pick up your weekly magazine your
newspaper
alongside that you can pick up your
bunch of flowers and it doesn't get more
convenient you know i find it quite
amazing because you know we'll think of
nothing of spending i don't know 1.50 in
a bar of chocolate that for one pound 50
you can buy
a bunch of sweet williams for two pounds
you can buy beautiful versus gladio
lights
brake car nations you know they're
things that will last more than just a
few hours they'll last for a week or so
but the supermarkets are committed to
selling cheaper british flowers
which has given a much needed financial
boost for our uk flower growers
i mean this is a selection of our
british cut flowers that are in season
at the moment so we've got sweet
williams which
are grown by a selection of growers less
than 100 miles from this store
instant smile
we've become trained to think of british
as better so if you go into your local
supermarket don't be at all surprised to
see
the union jack label on bunches of
flowers
for the british and years gone past
flowers were a real luxury item whereas
on the continent people bought them
every single day and the supermarket has
been very clever in retraining us to
think about flowers in that way too
so now we will add it in with our weekly
shop in a way we certainly wouldn't have
done in years gone past
supermarkets increasing domination of
the cut flower business
has divided britain's florists you can't
compete with supermarkets you can't
complete the garage four courts you just
have to be
completely different offer you have to
be better of better
customer service we pride ourselves on
that we sell sirloin we sell
philips we leave the stewing stake
values supermarkets the value mint to
the garage full courts
they do have some lovely flowers but
they sell certain different grade
flowers to us
you know you wouldn't see roses like
this in a supermarket
in beck's hill jeff's finally home after
spending two days at the dutch flower
auctions
[Music]
birds of paradise sharon i bought some
florists are a miserable bunch there's
uh
what's the point and carry on we're not
doing anything you know the supermarket
is taking all the trade and
there's always something there's never
them that's forward it's always somebody
else
i think supermarkets have done a hour of
good for us
they've pushed their flowers so you walk
into sainsbury's tesco's whatever
the first thing you see are their
flowers and because of that they're
educating people to buy flowers on a
weekly basis
we just got to wait for the people who
buy flowers get used to buying clouds in
a supermarket
then think well actually i'll go to a
local forest
and once they do i think they'll be
hooked
supermarkets have also helped our
british growers to survive competition
from foreign imports uk flower
production is up almost 10 percent this
year
in our own flower producing belt of
lincolnshire ward flowers
isn't quite as high high-tech as holland
but they produce an impressive 120
million stems a year of traditional
british flowers
they will be in september and out by
december okay so but
they have various weeks owner mark eaves
is having a regular visit from flower
buyer louise
mark supplies three of the uk's biggest
supermarkets
british flower production had been seen
as a bit of a cottage industry
but it's changing thanks to supermarkets
in the last 10 years british flower
production is up over 50
they're selling exceptionally well this
year so far but i think there's an
opportunity to make them even more
impactful for the customer
right the development stage on some of
them i think is a little bit too
backwards right that's about right i
would say
and what we're aiming to do is to get
this to look good in store
but not too good we want it to look its
best when it's actually in the person's
home or what have you but they want to
have a good experience from it we want
them to come back and say
oh look i want them they've done well
before
and keeping the best of british fresh is
easy for mark
luiza's main supermarket distribution
hub is only 15 miles away
surprisingly many british field-grown
flowers are better than those produced
in holland
[Music]
some of our traditional varieties don't
travel well so the dutch just can't
compete
[Music]
there isn't anything better in terms of
quality for the customer than the
british grown flower it's you know it's
i think i think to be fair the dutch do
grow on a slightly shorter time
therefore they're more heated and a lot
of times which is a different it's a
different type of product
it's not it's not the same looking
products as a british stock you know the
column length in the uk is a lot so
healthier and fuller more blooms a lot
more condensed the dutch stock is a lot
more stretched
we need to have a bit of dutch bravado
possibly
absolutely right i i think we're all a
bit
bit coy about what we actually do and
how good we are yeah absolutely
i think the difference is we're not
shouting it from the rooftops
and promoting that we're just getting on
with it that's the key difference i
think with the dutch
they like to chat about it we like to
get on with it
by buying british supermarkets cut out
the middleman
and the financial boost enables growers
like mark to invest
it's kind of proud really and we've made
that we've grown that
we've packed up and that's going
straight from here to store to
somebody's home
quite nice as well i think something
we've done in this little village has
actually gone across
the country wide a little bit of us
everywhere aren't it
the british cut flower industry is in no
way doomed i think it's got a very
strong future
but it's going to be in the hands of a
small number of very large
efficient growers we're always only
going to be producing
a proportion of uk sales for cut flowers
but it would be good if we could get it
up from say 10 to 25
which may well be realistic within the
next decade or two
and there's another british success
story that just may well save the uk's
flower industry
using the very best of british creative
talent carving out a new future
and taking on the world amazing
everyone's extremely happy
in front of the national gallery there's
a first time for everything
when it comes to the future of the
british flower industry things are
finally looking up
over the last 10 years cut flower
production in the uk is up over 50
there's an optimistic error covalent
garden their profits are up
and it's down to the growth of event
floristry high-end designer contracts
for special occasions and celebrations
uh somewhere same twenty
um what about day you see it as well
because it's like crunchy friday night
maybe like a pepperoni
yeah i look maybe not in your vape yeah
eventual wedding florist jay archer
is showing her latest batch of brides to
be around covent garden
where they're hoping to finalize the
flowers in their wedding bouquets
jay's committed to using exclusively
home-grown flowers
only around 10 sold in the uk are
british
john hardcastle is one of jay's major
suppliers
he's worked at covent garden for the
last 45 years
it's amazing today it's that time of
year where we're spoiled for selection
aren't we
jay's a new kid on the block she's only
been around for a couple of years
no these are stocks and done
fantastically well
appeared out of nowhere in a very short
time become quite a big player
i don't know where these jobs were 10 15
years ago
this is all new you know relatively new
this business and
it's a long way at rain it's great
jay's commitment to buying british could
be an example for other british forests
and help grow our flower industry
our expertise in high-end event
floristry is also carving out an
international reputation
and bringing in business i like the
sound
and it's happening here in a studio in
the back streets of south london
in this room are 30 of britain's finest
event florists
each one of these slabs takes 11
watering cans world-renowned british
florist robert hornsby
is taking the art of flower design to
epic heights
with probably the biggest most ambitious
display ever created
once the water starts wetting the inside
of the oasis it then starts pulling it
through but
he's only got two days to recreate an
exact copy of the famous painting
outside the national gallery in london's
trafalgar square
sort to all the flowers make sure we got
the right quantities for the right parts
of the picture
and literally for the next six or seven
eight hours
is putting every detail of every flower
into every part of the picture and then
hopefully by six o'clock tomorrow
it should look like a painting
it's a colossal challenge a living
sculpture
nine metres high using an amazing 30 000
freshly cut flowers
now only tulips for tulips
this is going right in the public eye
i've never done it before
i'm always the person that's going oh my
god i don't want to do this i can't
stand it i can't take this anymore
it's a very serious business very
serious was a lot of money
but ironically rob's copying the dutch
old master
and using exclusively dutch flowers and
that's not a coincidence
it's being sponsored by the flower
council of holland who promote flowers
from around the world
[Music]
it's 5 30 a.m in bedhampton hampshire
just need a bit of extra texture
and it just makes it work with its
natural surroundings
[Music]
jay is adding the finishing touches to
her clients wedding arrangements
i'm always nervous and she'll give the
bride her bouquet
once i know the bride's happy i'm all
right but i always feel a bit sick with
nerves until then
but just that one moment where she sees
it and
hopefully bursting to tears because she
loves it so much is just
there's no other feeling like it you
just to think that you've done that and
you've made someone's dreams come true
like i know it sounds a bit corny but
it's pretty mega it's pretty special
so all the foliage is british the
delphiniums are all british
stocks are all british so probably 75
of it is all british and most of our
weddings from may to september
are about 75 if not all um british
it's flowers nice of his niche to know
where you guys have come from um they're
fresher because they've not had to sort
of sit on a van for three days
and it's just nice to know that you're
supporting a
you know a british business so
[Music]
i love that when you see that at the
distance this is going to look almost
like a flower
rob's old master is finally coming alive
in southwark
it's a really amazing time to be a
florist because floristry is
pushing the boundaries much more than
ever has there's so much emotion tied up
in flowers there's something in us that
really responds to the colors and the
shapes and the fragrances
not just the nature in itself being
amazing but what pairs of hands have
done with it
to present it at its best yeah i think
there's a person alive that doesn't feel
something deep inside when they see that
kind of thing you know
i think the british flower industry has
a very bright future
your average high street florist is
probably not going to survive unless
they can
diversify and think differently about
the way they sell things
but at the high end of the market those
luxury bouquets that are supplying to
the top hotels
the whole industry of event floristry
that's really exciting
something that can be a real calling
card not just for the flower industry
but for the uk economy
i do love my british flowers and do hope
that one day is i think
certainly memento's building and there
will be more growers and they will have
the variety
and the industry will continue to grow
as it maybe did you know 40 50 years ago
but i think you know people are coming
back to it now people care about where
their food has come from they care about
where their clothes have come from
and i think flowers is just a natural
follow-on from that
i think flowers are quite an integral
part of life especially when you're
celebrating something or commiserating
and flower flowers can't die out rob's
floral jigsaw
is finally being assembled in front of
the national gallery
creating the giant easel if it works
it's hoped it will draw the crowds and
smash records for the gallery's dutch
masters exhibition
amazing everyone's extremely happy in
front of the national gallery
there's a first time for everything i'll
tell you there isn't anybody in this
world that i know
that doesn't love flowers to some extent
this is going to encourage people to
think about flowers more
and what they can do what they can say
for you
very differently i think it's fantastic
it really brings the pictures alive
and it's so clever i mean they've used
every element of
of the flowers to create this and it's
just
breathtaking absolutely breathtaking
the british flower industry may be
struggling to survive
but the dutch aren't having it all their
own way their subsidies are being cut
bolstered by the supermarkets and event
forestry consumers in the uk
are finally waking up to the power of
british source traditional flowers
after the foreign flower invasion the
brits are now fighting back
[Music]
british flowers are special because
they're supporting our british industry
we've got some
world-class growers over here and
ideally i'd like to see the public buy
more british ask for more british
inquire about the providence of your
flowers
give our growers a shot in the arm
[Music]
in the battle between british and dutch
flower growers the british will always
win when it comes to authenticity
but also because we want to buy the best
of british
and then this is your little bad boy oh
it's beautiful
i love it i'm so happy
[Music]
oh love it happy another
[Music]
[Music]
you